[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the new google pixel phone or two
phones the pixel and the pixel xl
they're picking up where nexus left off
with this whole stock android experience
thing and showcasing the absolute latest
of what's good with android so while
nexus phones were google working with
manufacturers like htc and lg and huawei
to make the phone pixel here is the
first phone made entirely by google
inside and out top to bottom the whole
thing so we're getting is a mostly
unibody aluminum phone here with some
chamfer action all the way around the
sides and an overall pretty round pretty
familiar shape
an antenna line goes across the bottom
of the back and you have the g logo the
google logo now at the bottom replacing
the nexus rip nexus and then you have
the top half of the back with this glass
panel around the fingerprint reader so
it's a pretty interesting dual tone look
dual texture look i might have to let it
grow on me for a little bit but wireless
charging wasn't mentioned at all at the
event so i'm not sure if this has any
utility but just a different look and up
front is the amoled display which looks
great and on the white version of the
phone above the display you can see some
cluster of sensors although the black
version of the phone i think definitely
hides this a lot better as you'd expect
and i think i like the overall look of
the black phone a little bit better
anyway it's kind of my thing and i can't
seriously be the first one to mention
that chin wow like is it really
necessary to keep the phone symmetrical
i actually liked the nexus 6 look of
having a smaller chin because it's not
necessary to have a big chin the
fingerprint reader is on the back the
home and navigation buttons are on the
screen so i would have loved to have
seen a smaller chin up here
but oh well so the only difference
between the pixel and pixel xl is the
size the display size up front and the
battery size the 5.5 inch display of the
xl and the 5 inch display of the pixel
everything else the specs the camera
everything else is identical so speaking
of specs this is shaping up to be
possibly the fastest phone ever
again it's rocking a snapdragon 821 chip
so it's the first phone to do that four
gigabytes of ram and 32 or 128 gigabytes
of storage it has usb type c at the
bottom where the speakers are as you can
see and quick charging claims to get
seven hours of charge in 15 minutes oh
and don't worry it still does have a
headphone jack feels crazy every time i
have to say that but it's true it's
still up here at the top and the camera
on the back claims claims to be the best
on any smartphone by their
pre-production dxo mark ranking now i
can't even keep track of how many
smartphones have claimed that anymore
but it is promising it's a 12 megapixel
camera with a really big sensor so 1.55
micron pixels which are some of the
biggest i've seen in a while it's
basically ultra pixels at this point f
2.0 aperture 4k video and that led flash
and with the software optimization
they're saying there's basically zero
shutter lag so you can take photos super
quickly so that's definitely something i
gotta test more when i get it the few
photos i did take in this environment
they look decent but this is like the
worst lighting possible so i'll have to
get out and test that for the full
review for sure and yeah this is all
launching with android 7.1 on board so
it looks like it'll be the first and
only phone right out the box to get that
and playing with it i found it pretty
nice now the round icons and the couple
new ui tweaks i can get used to that i
mean at least all the icons are the same
size now but the rest of android 7.1 is
a bunch of new features and little
additions to 7.0 the main one of those
being the google assistant now google
assistant isn't new it was in google's
allo app you can use that already but
now they've built it into the os itself
so it's replacing what was essentially
google now on tap where that used to be
so now anywhere in any app on any screen
you can long press the home button to
get the little pop-up for google
assistant and for there you can ask it a
question you can ask it about people
places things ask it to remind you
something or start playing music
chromecast whatever it's your assistant
it does all that stuff now you can still
get the google now on tap features by
swiping so if you still want that
awesome screen recognition stuff you can
long press on the screen and swipe up
and you'll have the now on tap features
but yeah the assistant and all its
machine learning awesomeness is a major
new feature a major point for android
7.1 and the rest of the things i noticed
were pretty little like in the settings
there's a new tab over to the right
called support where you have direct
links to calling or video chatting with
tech support the new home button
animation you saw it when i've long
pressed it but there's this new fancy
animation every time you regularly press
home and it's quick but it's nice you
can't really miss it and this new
animated lock screen thing check this
out look at the like the canyon picture
when i unlock it
see it moving like that's crazy that has
to be new right or at least the images
built in for the support are super good
looking now but anyway that's what's
good the first impressions for me right
off the bat with the pixel phone and
with the pixel launcher are a bit of a
mixed bag for sure uh of the three new
colors i would say the black one is my
favorite not a surprise but not gonna
lie that blue is actually pretty good
looking in certain light but you're
gonna wanna love it to spend that
premium price that this phone is going
to come in at it's starting at 649
unlocked which makes sense for the build
you're getting and the specs you're
getting but you're gonna have to really
like it so i'm hoping to get my hands on
this and the daydream vue headset later
this year and google home and chromecast
ultra and everything they announced but
in the meantime let me know what you
think of pixel and pixel xl is this your
next phone is this enough to convince
you to spend your money i think the full
review will be a lot of fun so
definitely subscribe for that and be
sure to share this video your one stop
shop for all information all things
pixel until it comes out anyway thank
you for watching i'll talk to you guys
the next one peace
[Music]